die handwerk 14 bildete das übungs
mäßige brigade schwergewicht der vierten
panzergrenadierbrigade im ersten
halbjahr 2014 die klassischen
einsatzarten angriff verzögerung und
verteidigung wurden unter maximaler
ausnutzung des truppenübungsplatzes
allen steck geübt ziel der übung war der
kampf der verbundenen waffen unter
annahme der bekämpfung eines
konventionellen gegners insgesamt waren
mehr als 2000 soldatinnen und soldaten
an der übung beteiligt 80 gepanzerte
gefechtsfahrzeuge sowie circa 280 räder
fahrzeuge und zwei bewaffnete
hubschrauber kamen im zuge der 114 zum
einsatz
die handwerk wirksam steht auch die
abschlussübung des eindrucks termines
september 2013 da die grundwehrdiener
erhielten die gelegenheit ihre zuvor
erlernten fähigkeiten als höhepunkt
ihrer ausbildung unter einsatz
rahmenbedingungen im scharfen schuss
umzusetzen und anzuwenden
neben unterschiedlichen nationalen und
internationalen delegationen namen auf
circa 500 grundwehrdiener aus ganz
österreich die möglichkeit wahr einen
ausschnitt des kampftruppen schießens
aus einem beobachter raum mitzuerleben
durch diese umfassende einweisung von
grundwehrdienern stellte dieses
scharfschießen eine wesentliche
initiative zur attraktivierung des
grundwehrdienstes da die übung 114
erfüllte ihren zweck nämlich den erhalt
und ausbau der militärischen
kernfähigkeiten der führungsfähigkeit
und der einsatzbereitschaft und
zusammenhang mit der attraktivierung des
grundwehrdienstes